hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from round one of the steinitz
Memorial and our Stannis Memorial is the
second leg of the five-legged tournament
well basically a series of tournaments
that is the Magnus Carlsen chest or so
basically like the Grantchester only
online and with the prize fund of 1
million dollars so the first tournament
Magnus Invitational was only the first
leg then we have the Danish memorial
this game is a part of that then we have
the win Doris ABI rapid tournament then
the chess Legends tournament who I have
no idea what is maybe some chess legends
will join them and of course in fifth is
the the grand final or something like
that but yeah it's really an interesting
game but before that I would just like
to congratulate everyone for playing the
arena yesterday here are the winners of
the meadow arena
Abubakar Mattie gets and lightning X
cube and followed by Steve max Val 93
Cora bite nasty discoveries good handle
raid the necromancer 695 and amanada and
also the winner the winners of the
minivan D agamotto Friday arena call -
90 that's a feedom Esther Carmelita from
Poland super gm1 from Serbia and me file
2002 that's me holly acrolein from
croatia
so congratulations guys and followed by
a th for for one medio shattuck
cyclonite travis numata whole house and
the VAR at 45 so congratulations
everyone for participating and winning
and now we go to the game but also today
I will be premiering my podcast with
Maxime wash Ella Grasso now if you're
interested in checking it out I will put
a link to it in the description below
it's the first thing you will see it's
some two hours long so if you don't have
the time you can always check it out
later
and after the game Maxime and I played
one blitz game and I also made a
separate video on that but that video
will become available as soon as the
podcast
finish finishes premiering and the link
to that will also be in the description
of the podcast but it will also receive
a notification if you are subscribed so
that being said let's check out this
game Magnus vs Peter Svidler and Magnus
for his first move as the thumbnail
suggests a ghost one c3 now Magnus
play 1c3 Magnus also announced it a few
days ago on Twitter saying that my boy
Albert Apple Berta is a sailor's handle
on Twitter better be ready for 1 C 3 e 5
c4 Knight of 6 Knight the C 3 B 4 end
age 4 in the first round so it's it says
if Magnus issued a challenge thing that
he will play that and if Hitler wants to
rise up to the challenge he has to
follow those moves and indeed littler
followed those moves so we have C 3 e 5
and now Magnus just goes c4 so basically
giving black the move as you could have
just gone of course c4 right away and
now Knight to f6 and black will have a
significant lead in development to do to
this well 1 move handicap nice to see 3
with Bishop to b4 and now already
Svidler has a night out to Bishop out
the ponies nicely now on e5 and the
magnets goes for h4 here now there are
actually is one game in the database
where g3 was played but here h4 is a new
move so already as of move four we have
a completely new game now so wheeler
castles here and we have III by Magnus
preparing d4 that we have c6 wheeler
wants to get the d5 in and now the
immediate the g4 starting the attack on
the Kings side as the lore says okay I'm
not really interested in that he just
continues with d5 strikes in the center
and we have g5 by Magnus dislodging the
night from f6 Knight the e8 and now just
a3 asking do you want to capture do you
want to go to a five and maybe c7 or do
you want to go back to east 7 seller
decides to go back to east 7 and now as
d4 is definitely coming
Magnus straight on d5 Capra's captures
and then pushes d5 lady for himself
we have eek actress on d4 II capture Sun
d4 and now Knight to c6 continuing
development and now Bishop the g2 puts
pressure on the d5 as now it's attacked
twice sauce wheeler defends it Knight
the CC 7 and now Knight G to E 2 are
preparing to go to f4 or G 3 depending
on what black place so here as filler
continues development with Bishop to f5
and now it's a good opportunity to get
the knight to g3 as the bishop on f5 is
undefended and you can't go to g6 if you
go to Jesus then h5 is just too strong
you're gonna have to go
back or something and then after the
bishop is captured you can go d5 and
it's just a really really great position
for white and the black epon is even
helping you avoid any threats along the
e-file now so instead of Bishop back the
e6 by slid ler and now we have castles
by Magnus and now comes Queen to d7
developing the Queen also keeping an eye
on DF v square as a white we definitely
enjoy playing f4 f5 so Bishop to f4
Magnus also continuous development in
the rook a to D 8 we have rook to e1 and
now look after year it's so both black
and white finish development Magnus
still needs to get the the a1 rook into
the game so that's why Queen to d3 a3
has been played so you don't have to
worry about night before and now the
rook is also coming into the game
trailer goes Bishop to d6 puts pressure
on the bishop on f4 and Magnus defends
it with Knight to h5 but now Seville or
goes for Bishop to g4 now attacking the
knight and now how do you defend against
this well Magnus finds a very
interesting idea rook captures any age
with check rook captures and now Bishop
captures and d6 now we have Queen
captures on d6 and now Queen the g3 as a
swell as Queen on d6 is unprotected so
there's a double attack now and you have
to trade or you can just go back to
defend the bishop but then then the
knife can just go back to f4 so here
swindler goes for the trade we have
characters captures in the now Knight
characters and d4 so we have a trade of
points in the center and Knight
characters on d4 Knight captures and d5
Knight captures and b5 and Bishop sorry
that's not a Bishop Bishop characters on
d5 and we get this end game where it's a
bishop against tonight against the widow
Bishop against the night and two rooks
with two points on the Queen side each
each and three points on the Kings side
each with Carlson's pawns on the Kings
side being a bit more advanced however
it's hard to decide if this is a plus or
a minus with the blacks and nice control
here and the rook being able to enter
the game a black should be somewhat
better
so here's Villar not interested in
defending the pawn he starts improving
the position of his King so Magnus grabs
that but it's only temporary because
rook to b8 Magnus has to go back with
Bishop the e4 and now
cat person be to look to see one finally
the rook enters the game and now of
course you have to see if this check is
doing anything not really as the Bishop
covers c8 so we have just looked the b3
going after the pawn here but now rook
the c4 not going after the night so here
it's filler traits
well not trade but he goes for Knight to
f3 check and the Magnus decides to
capture with Bishop captures at Bishop
captures and now Knight to f5 so it's a
bit dangerous for both sides but the
problem is after a ruby one check and
the rook h1 check that the White King
can escape the g3 and now with the e7
square covered as filter has to be very
careful about rook to c8 checkmate so of
course he starts to bringing the King
further into the game King Teti 8 and
now rook the c7 putting pressure on the
a7 pawn also threatening Knight d4
Knight d6 check to pick up the f7 pawn
so here we have Bishop to d5 guarding f7
pawn but now you part with the g7 pawn
so Knight characters on g7 width check
King to d8 and now rook the c5 going
after the bishop as wheeler goes back
Bishop to b7 and now look the a5
defending and attacking on a7 and here
as filler finds a very nice idea rook to
h3 which threatens checkmate but also if
you defend checkmate you can also lose
the h4 point so Magnus quickly goes King
to f1 and similar grabs the pawn rook
captures on h4 and we have now rook
captures on a7 which is a which is a
deadly mistake here rook captures an a7
completely blunders the game for Magnus
and the game is now lost so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the move
that wins the game for Svidler while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the mating
pattern and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy show its Bishop to f3 and
it's unavoidable
to get made it with white the problem is
there's a rook to h1 checkmate the
bishop car is G 2 and e2 and you might
be thinking but yeah but I just go King
you want and there's no mate well you
would be wrong because then rook d4 and
now Bishop still
covers e 2 and E 1 and rook to d1 is now
an unstoppable mate there's no defense
against this even if you go to f1 it's
still checkmate so it's so it's a really
cool idea which now that you know you
should remember it and you might spot it
in your own game
so just Bishop f3 and hey if the king in
escapes then you just root before and
there is no escape however after this
rook captures an 87 movie Spiller played
King to c7 he missed the idea and now
Carlson is back in the game he plays
rook a5 and now the problem is the same
idea no longer works if Bishop f3
you're gonna go king he won and rook
before his met with rook c5 check and
then you defend with rook to c1 so the
mating pattern no longer exists however
it would be it would give black a very
nice position
swivel er instead goes for h6 and we
have G captures and h6 rook captures and
rook to f5 now sorry not see if I cook
the f5 now I'm going after the f7 pawn
bishop the a6 check we have kink that a1
and now rook to h3 and going after the
a3 pawn this way we have rook captures
on f7 with check King to b6 and now F 3
are blocking the rooks attack towards
the pawn rook the 8:1 check which we are
now shifting the rook over to the Queen
side King f2 and now rook all the way to
a 1 with rook f6 check King to a5 and
now rook captures on a3 sorry first
night 96 and rook captures an a3 so
soother wins the pawn and now it's 1
point again 0 points so Kent Magnus make
use of his extra pawn with Knight to d4
preparing to bring the King into the
game and start pushing the past pawn
Bishop to c4 and King to g3 now we have
King Tubby force feeler also has to
bring his skin closer to the action and
here Magnus returns the favor here white
is completely winning I'm sure you see
how without pausing the video but it's a
3 plus tube it bleeds game so of course
when both players are very long time you
don't expect us wheeler to make a
mistake like this so night c2 just picks
up the rook and it's game over but
Magnus returns the favor and he misses
it he plays King to a4 just wants to get
his King further up the board to start
pushing the pawn and now King c3 by
Seville
we have King to e4 and now rook the a 8
we have Knight to c6 and now Bishop to
e2 now the idea is that well yeah
there's always danger of sacrificing the
bishop before the pawn so white will be
unable to checkmate you so f4 and now
rook the a4 with check we have King the
e5 and now Bishop to f3 putting pressure
on the night we have f5 Magnus continues
to push the pass pawn and now Rock a six
with a double attack on the night here
so Hitler Magnus goes in Knight study
for and now comes Luke captures on f6
saying that if King characters I'm just
gonna capture the knight to put my
bishop here and when your pawn reaches
f7 I'm just gonna give up my bishop for
the pawn and it will be a draw by
insufficient material so we have Knight
the b5 check Magnus tries to keep some
pieces into the game but came to d2 we
have King Capra's on f6 and now comes
Bishop to g4 and there is no more there
are no more ways to continue this game
as next move as well we will just pick
up the f5 point and it's a draw so King
to e5 was played by Magnus endsville or
just played Bishop captures an f5 and it
was in his position that the players
agreed to a draw so really really wild
game Magnus issuing the challenge a few
days prior to the actual game as filler
accepts the challenge and it's a really
crazy game so it ler had a forced mate
in 7 with that bishops remaining pattern
and cross and could have one with the
nice fork but you know both of them
missed it in the end it's a draw so a
fair result and a good game for them and
I do hope you enjoyed it as well so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
do check out the podcast today like I
said the link is in the description
below first thing you will see so do
check it out it's it's the first time
I'm premiering a video so you you are
even able to chat with other people
before the premiere actually starts so
it's I don't know I've never used it but
it seems like a like a nice feature and
yeah I would I would also like to think
again as I read better called rough
shocker I mean Alessio particle look the
Montini and oliver back for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serum
thank you for watching
and I will see you soon our continuing
the coverage of the Morphy saga when I
managed as there's simply too much going
on at the moment
continuing the coverage of the Stannis
memorial and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your Saturday